a clear mandate from the people of
Greece for the radical left leader
Alexis tsipras and the morning after the
party a demand from MEP s he use his
mandate and drive reform missin tsipras
is getting stronger for the same time
you know he just got support from people
and I think that also means that his
responsibility for taking Greece out of
the crisis it grows I mean he's now
responsible without any doubt for
everything that can happen to Greece in
the years to come just real javi the
worker like go shagging a pre took what
protodeacon enjoy the body politic the
hollows marry politics austerity tell
calzone with the money on reddit I
didn't many actually radical hear me
like his laws and he would profit
Airport on the pre pre continue after
knife-edge negotiations before the
summer Greece received an additional 86
billion euro bailout eurozone partners
demanding more austerity and gigantic
reforms now some allies are talking
about death relief even the IMF deeply
is convinced that if there is not
renegotiation of the depth at all Greece
never will be able to repay the money
and so I guess he has to increase the
awareness of his partners in Z will
institutions a tall order considering
the reform challenges mr. tsipras faces
at home and the expectations of his
European partners of success